i want my baby back baby baby baby i
want my baby back baby
i want my baby chili's
baby back ribs
i want my baby back baby
baby back ribs
chili's
chili's baby back ribs
no way out the second one okay
[Laughter]
i look forward to drug testing
i used to get a runner's high
which is why now i lift
chin
i look forward to drug testing
but urinating is not something
this is not a joke this is not a
carnival
kind of bad
nice job nice work
this is busiest
beaver i know it says busiest no no you
screwed that up didn't you
i guess we have to go back don't we
we're wasting a lot of tape give me that
[Music]
come on phyllis come on
oh jesus are you all right
fellas are you all right are you okay
i'm okay
don't don't you even keep that in there
oh my god
[Laughter]
i think i'm going to need some new pants
[Laughter]
oh
you broke it
you broke it
[Laughter]
oh man this pit will never work oh
wow
and
this copier
is
working fine that's the original well
we're having an earthquake get it on the
dvd
the train is going through scranton what
happened to foreign it's okay two
minutes is too soon five minutes and two
minutes is a very big difference
together right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
i told you like five minutes well what
happened to four and three because two
minutes doesn't do us any good come here
no what chicago
property you're looking at is in great
shape and the equipment's 100 pristine
are you looking to preserve it
whoa whoa something major happened
wasn't my fault installed poorly okay
i know bob vance dwight schrute i work
next door just give him a call
call bob vance call bob vance
bob
just
forget it mr schrute are you looking to
preserve it as a munitions plan just
i'll call you back
oh my god
what's your point here's my point
here's the church here's the steeple
open it up
there's all the people cheating on other
people
okay do this do this
[Laughter]
you knew
exactly where that was going
hey dwight
the mall is corrupt
molly's evil their appearances
jim that is so inappropriate
you guys like the chat absolutely get
these done out out
hello hey
here to talk about woof oh that's cool
yes definitely as long as you're here to
tell me i'm a billionaire you're
on your way man on your way
sorry
no no it's great i love working at
dunder mifflin taliban branch
bloop
no it's great ooh
uh oh no it's great how low we're going
to generate my breath
we have three
sex or
heavy petting closets one masturbation
closet
does anyone have a problem with that
yes gay closet five that wasn't like
five
that wasn't the problem three heavy
padding closets one masturbation closet
and one gay class absolutely yes
no problem everybody happy with the
glory holes
what well i just i heard about it
somewhere holy fifth closet will have a
glory hole
[Laughter]
now i know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what
that's a risk
we have today
that is
that is a risk that we have to no no no
i know what you're saying why do you
keep going
hey i know what you're thinking won't
that just [ __ ]
i know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
that is a risk we need to take
pam thank you
pam why don't you work with phallus and
draw a picture of the exposure
i want it on my desk by the end of the
day or you will receive a full
desaturation
what's that
john cracks
we had a funeral for a bird
i'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not real
huh
do we have any muffins
yeah
take a longer pause before you answer
pat
i don't know if you like country music
but i was thinking maybe one of these
days
god bless america
would you please sign my company
directory
i'm about people
okay
good
okay
something like that the hell is that
i want to see this penis
i don't mean to be crass but get
prepared to get wet
because
[Laughter]
wow
there was no double meaning in that
there wasn't you couldn't even get
through it
it's the most horrible thing i'm so
sorry i guess what surround sound means
is that right over here
[Laughter]
two speakers
damn
we have two speakers
what
honey oh jesus
this is terrible never finish this
episode
um check this out
folds
oh my god
okay michael i might have someone for
you
here she's really sweet and nice you
guys might actually get along
is she hot
that was such a bad day
that was the worst take ever
you
are
are
are you are
are you
[Laughter]
dwight
[Laughter]
dwight
[Laughter]
dwight
you